so in may of 2021 a prominent blm
activist um black nationalist and future
attempted assassin quintes brown wrote
another op-ed for the louisville courier
journal titled louisville's huge police
budget is the real bogeyman traumatizing
black people now in the piece he talks
about all the ways that he as a black
man has suffered because of the police
in his city
and the best way to heal his trauma he
argues and rescue the city from violence
is to reduce the police budget
and he claims that louisville police are
are not good at preventing crime anyway
and so the best way to solve that
problem is to give them fewer resources
to work with it's a it's actually a
familiar argument always coming from the
same people who say that every problem
in the education system can be solved
by increasing the budget
so to review if police aren't doing
their jobs effectively give them less
money if teachers aren't doing their
jobs effectively give them more striking
logic you must admit but this article
from brown was the last that he would
write for the publication one of the
first back in 2019 was a lamentation
about the lack of gun control in
kentucky and across the country brown
claimed that kentucky's concealed carry
law shows your life doesn't matter to
gun-loving republicans
in between this article and his arrest
this past weekend for trying to shoot
and kill a white mayoral candidate in
the city brown was intricately involved
in blm activism and he was honored for
his activism actually hailed by barack
obama's foundation as a rising face
in the social justice movement he became
a member of the youth violence
prevention league if you can believe it
and he was a local political candidate
for metro council district five
so sky sky got around a couple years ago
he was given a platform on msnbc
where joy reid interviewed him about uh
this same problem of gun violence listen
to this
you're from the home state of the senate
majority leader what do you want what do
you want him to know well i want you to
know that you know
we are here and we won't we won't common
sense gun reform and if you're not going
to give us that then we're going to get
everyone out here to vote and we're
going to vote you out of office so if
you want to keep your job yeah then you
know give us what we not what we want
but what we need what humans need we
need common sense gun reform get rid of
those heart rifles come on like yeah
when are you guys gonna turn 18. i'll
turn 18 september 25th i'm already timed
and already registered
29 so we're registered and you guys are
making the connection that you believe
that this is about being in the voting
booth definitely uh emma gonzalez she
already put an emphasis on it like
because we do have some very inflexible
congressmen so maybe we won't get gun
reform like the next day but non-violent
direct action takes time it's not going
to happen overnight so one thing that we
can do is get people out here voting
because even if we don't get gun reform
we're going to vote the people in office
out and we're going for people who want
gun reform who care about us we're going
to put them in offices
non-violent direct action takes time and
uh he gave it about i don't know 18
months before he started shooting people
but quentin brown is tired of gun
violence he says so tired of it that he
allegedly walked into mayoral candidate
craig greenberg's office and shot at him
at close range and missed every shot
somehow now fairness brown does say in
the clip that he wants to get rid of
assault rifles whatever those are he
doesn't say anything about a nine
millimeter which is what he used in his
assassination attempt so you know talk
about a loophole but no matter what sort
of gun he used the end result is that a
prominent and celebrated black
nationalist blm activist tried to
assassinate a politician in a major
american city this happened yesterday
morning and it's already out of the
headlines
because this is the part of the story
that comes as no surprise it's the part
of the story where the story disappears
already you can check the home pages of
cnn msnbc nbc news etc all the usual
suspects and find no mention at all
anywhere of quintez brown the memory
hole is dark and deep and it does not
suck things into itself slowly like
quicksand instead it will obliterate
unwanted facts and events in the blink
of an eye
the media of course has gotten very good
at quickly and quietly snuffing out
stories of black nationalists and blm
activists committing politically
motivated murders
because they've had a lot of practice it
was only a few months ago that another
member of this ideological group
plowed his car into dozens of white
people in a parade intentionally
targeting them injuring over 60 people
killing six including a child
in waukesha
that story was on its way to getting
tossed into the pit as soon as the race
of the perpetrator was known and then
when his politic politics came into
focus its fate was sealed
but before waukesha and in the same year
a capital police officer was murdered
when a black nationalist named noah
green rammed his car into a barricade
and attacked cops with a knife
officer brian siknik was was not
actually killed by rioters on january 6
though you know his name because the
media attempted to connect the two
events
but in this case a capitol police
officer was actually murdered by a
political extremist
straight up murder
you don't know his name it was william
evans by the way because his death was
not useful to the narrative
you also probably don't remember the
so-called black hebrew israelites who
shot up a jewish delhi in new jersey
it's only a couple of years ago then got
into a shootout with the cops ultimately
left six people dead
hopefully though you remember the
extremists who assassinated five police
officers with a sniper rifle at a blm
rally in dallas in 2016 though the media
is so effective at erasing these events
from the public consciousness that even
that massacre seems to have been
mostly forgotten by the public
you know we hear quite a lot about the
the looming threat of white nationalism
and yet the majority of murderers in
this country and the majority of murders
are carried out by people who don't
quite fit that description
and even if we were to narrow the
category down to ideologically or
politically or racially motivated
violence
still most culprits don't exactly look
like white nationalists
blm itself and its various ideological
cousins and offshoots
is by far and away the most dangerous
and violent organization in america
second only to planned parenthood
perhaps
blm activists have been involved in
targeted acts of violence like this
assassination attempt also large-scale
campaigns of brutal chaos and anarchy
entire neighborhoods and cities have
been consumed by this whirlwind for days
and weeks on end
now a violent political movements and
organizations
have always existed in this country and
and always will
in this country and across the world and
everywhere for all time as long as
they're along as long as there's
politics
as long as there's human society there
are going to be violent political
movements and violent people
now in some ways you might argue that
blm isn't much different from the ones
that came before it or will come after
it in that way but the difference
and what makes blm so uniquely dangerous
is that it has systemic support we hear
a lot about the problems in the system
systemic well it has systemic support
it's propped up encouraged funded
facilitated
by the most powerful institutions in the
country
now this is also why right-wing
extremists so-called
could never be as dangerous as blm even
if they wanted to wanted to be
and i'm sure that some of them do
i'm sure some of them look at blm and
say i wish we could do that
but they can't
because no matter what they do they
can't get amazon on their side
or facebook or the education system or
the government
blm has all of that and it has the media
of course
and the media's most important job on
blm's behalf
is to make sure that we all have very
short memories
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content